Dimitar vient presque tous les jours
c'est grâce à ça qu'ils ne sont pas
la travailler
pour moi
[Musique]
tout petit je rêvais des réseaux sauver
secourir protéger finalement j'ai changé
de cap je suis journaliste et j'ai
décidé d'aller à la rencontre de ces
hommes et de ces femmes ordinaires qui
exercent des métiers hors du commun
aujourd'hui je suis avec les maraudeurs
qui accompagnent les 100 abris à Paris
yokana
en 2013 en France
45300 abris sont morts dans la rue c'est
une bouche d'aération les gens ils
dorment là quoi
pour tenter d'en finir avec cette
catastrophe humanitaire ils sont des
centaines à arpenter le macadam de Paris
c'est important
que tu souhaites on les appelle les
maraudeurs réchauffer nourrir maintenir
un lien social et là tu
ou professionnel les maraudeurs ont le
même objectif
lutter contre l'exclusion des grands
oubliés de la ville
[Musique]
chaque année 16 millions de touristes se
bousculent à Paris l'une des villes les
plus visitées du monde mais la vie de
lumière assaisonne d'ombre plus de 30
000 SDF squat c'est trottoir dans la rue
l'espérance de vie dépassera rarement
les 42 ans
il est 19h
j'ai rendez-vous en bord de Seine sur la
péniche florons Saint-Jean un refuge
pour sans abri tenu par l'Ordre de Malte
la plus vieille association humanitaire
du monde
bonjour Christophe enchanté enchanté
celui qui m'accueille c'est
Jean-Baptiste il fait partie des 4500
bénévoles que compte l'ordre de malt en
France et ce soir Jean-Baptiste endos la
casquette de maraudeur bonjour ça va
bien salut
Jean-Baptiste et les autres bénévoles
font des rondes pour offrir boisson
chaude et nourriture au plus démunis
a choisi de donner un peu de son temps
[Musique]
peut-être que je suis allé chercher dans
une petite réserve une couverture
à l'ordre de Malte qu'on n'arrive jamais
les mains vides les marades doivent
servir à combler les besoins les plus
élémentaires
le camion est presque chargé
avant le départ j'en profite pour faire
connaissance avec mes camarades d'un
soir
juste comme ça pour les présentations
parce que vous êtes des bénévoles oui
tout à fait moi je travaille dans la
dans la banque et effectivement c'est
bien l'équilibrer ça avec avec des
actions comme ça en parallèle donc voilà
le monde de l'argent le jour est des
sans argent
en fait je travaillais dans le monde de
l'art dans la haute couture haute
couture banque les bénévoles vivent
souvent loin du monde de la rue et voilà
Franck bonjour Christophe
Franck le troisième Laron est
responsable logistique dans
l'aéronautique
qu'est-ce qui peut pousser ces cadres
supérieurs à enfiler le blouson du
Maraudeur
que j'ai fait quand j'étais étudiant
j'étais ambulancier à la Croix Rouge
d'accord qu'est-ce que j'ai fait encore
puis-je donner à manger au clochard
aussi dans une paroisse dans le 10e
je suis d'accord voilà quoi en fait ça
s'inscrit dans des traditions tout ça
dans une histoire
on peut rester dans notre confort ou
notre inconfort d'ailleurs mais ça
permet de relativiser pendant pas mal de
trucs
relativiser quitter son confort les
maraudeurs de l'Ordre de Malte sont
plutôt discrets sur leur motivation
allez on décolle
et c'est parti pour 4h de Maroc nous
roulons dans un quartier chic de la
capitale ici de mètre carré à voisine
les 10000 euros et la misère fait tâches
à peine avant nous démarrer que déjà la
camionnette s'arrête
l'équipe a repéré un jeune homme
il est allongé à même le trottoir
sur une avenue huppée du 7e et il ne
bouge pas
un café quoi si vous voulez venir avec
nous
visiblement ce jeune allongé contre la
vitrine d'un salon de manucure
trouble les riverains
[Musique]
la conversation s'avère plus difficile
que prévu notre interlocuteur n'est pas
bavard
ne parle pas français et son anglais est
très approximatif
nous comprenons que ce jeune Allemand
souffre d'une déception sentimentale
ce serait donc un chagrin d'amour qui
l'a conduit sur ce trottoir anonyme très
loin de chez lui nous n'en saurons pas
plus il ne veut pas de notre aide
un jeune c'est un blanc ça trouble quoi
et plutôt beau gosse en plus
[Musique]
on fait la demande les maraudeurs
peuvent l'accompagner dans un
hébergement d'urgence mais s'il préfère
rester dans la rue il faut respecter son
choix ce qu'a bien du mal à comprendre
cette voisine c'est vraiment
maintenant exactement donc
ça leur permettrait de mieux dormir
faites dans ces carrés de ce quartier je
pense que des gens c'est mélanger ils
veulent à la fois là
à la fois aider les gens et puis qu'on
les enlève devant chez eux
à mon avis ce monsieur n'aime ni les SDF
ni les journalistes
[Musique]
la soirée est loin d'être finie
nous repartons en direction d'un autre
arrondissement
pourra descendre la rue de Rennes tu
sais et il y a souvent la sous les
Porsche des magasins fermés en fait
souvent des SDF là qui sont là et ils
veulent pas forcément être hébergés ils
sont très bien où ils sont
mais ils sont contents de prendre un
café ou une petite un petit Bolino
rue de Rennes l'une des artères les plus
commerçantes de Paris ici des centaines
de boutiques et de restaurants
s'étendent sur plus d'un kilomètre
l'endroit est bien connu des Maraudeurs
lorsque les magasins tirent le rideau la
rue devient un immense dortoir à ciel
ouvert
[Musique]
deux ans
chaque soir entre les petites culottes
et les soutiens-gorges comment s'est-il
retrouvé là je tente d'entamer le
dialogue à l'aide du traducteur de mon
téléphone portable quel âge il a ce
monsieur
70 ans
et vous avez une maison en Roumanie
maison Roumanie
grand-père le traducteur de mon portable
a ses limites et ceux qui vivent dans la
rue sont très pudiques il n'aime pas
raconter leur vie
votre nom
votre nom moi Jean-Baptiste
nous reprenons notre route dans la
camionnette
Annick a un petit coup de blues cette
rencontre la trouble plus que d'habitude
ça peut être un peu émouvant parfois
c'est toujours étonnant de voir des vies
comme ça sur le trottoir on connaît pas
leur histoire et c'est un peu parfois
c'est impressionnant
nous n'aurons pas le temps de
philosopher l'équipe a déjà repéré
d'autres sans-abris un peu plus loin
[Musique]
ils veulent des chaussettes
visiblement il s'agit d'un groupe de
trois personnes par mesure de sécurité
je dois attendre le signal pour
approcher ils sont bons
en même temps j'ai l'habitude depuis le
temps que je fais ce métier je sais
pertinemment que la caméra peut rendre
les gens agressifs
une fois encore ces trois hommes
viennent de Roumanie
je m'apprête à dégainer mon traducteur
mais cette fois ça ne sera pas utile il
y a un interprète dans le trio
25 ans mais qu'est-ce que vous faites en
France
moi je suis bien moi j'ai
j'ai un petit boulot ici je travaille
très bien et vous dormez où moi je donne
un appartement dans tous les principes
notre traducteur s'appelle Gabriel il ne
dort pas dans la rue mais il vit à tous
les soirs tenir compagnie à ses
compatriotes moins chanceux
de la même village
d'accord c'est pour ça je pourrais te
connecter petit Jean depuis tout petit
et quand je l'ai vu j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais toi aussi tu es à
Paris oui de toute la Roumanie va venir
les Français ils voulaient pas
je dis c'est pas tout à fait vous vous
faites pas de bêtises mais il y a des
autres par exemple les gitans qui fait
des grandes bêtises si vous restez comme
ça vous faites pas de grandes bêtises
mais vous demandez pas vous restez comme
ça c'est quelqu'un qui veut mettre bien
mais il y a des autres qui cassent tous
les magasins
la réflexion de Gabriel laisse songeur
c'est
[Musique]
compliqué c'est chaud
je veillerai à ne plus considérer que
les Roumains de Paris sont tous des Roms
visiblement Gabriel et ses amis
redoutent la confusion
maintenant j'ai honte de dire que je
suis au monde
quand je me Recon avec quelqu'un je dis
que je suis
hollandaise je sais pas quoi parce que
si je dis que je suis ou non vous êtes
vraiment salut non mais tu as de la
chance ce que nous interlocuteurs ne
réalisent pas c'est qu'ils ont un point
commun avec les Roms si les robes
quittent la Roumanie c'est aussi parce
que les Romains les aiment pas donc
voilà on retrouve la boucle se boucle
mais chez nous
il est bien lui
Rome
roumain ce soir-là nous en avons croisé
des dizaines parfois leurs déchéance
est-elle que les approcher presque un
acte de bravoure et une bonne douche
ferait du bien à ce monsieur
mais pour les bénévoles de l'Ordre de
Malte la nationalité l'histoire le
niveau d'hygiène des personnes n'a
aucune importance
je sais que c'est la question qui qui
revient toujours c'est pourquoi pourquoi
on fait ça et pourquoi pourquoi on
continue je sais pas c'est des natures
oui pour qu'on le ferait pas je pense
qu'il y a aussi oui il y a des natures
qui sont prêtes à le faire donc comme il
y a quand même beaucoup de gens qui ont
besoin des autres voilà ce soir c'est
nous
en 4 heures de maraude nous avons
parcouru Paris de long en large merci
beaucoup merci bonne journée merci bonne
journée c'est marrant vous connaissez la
France la seule phrase qu'il faut dire
quand on vous donne des sous merci bonne
journée
et distribuer des litres de soupe et de
café
il est plus de minuit nous rentrons au
port nous n'avons pas changé le monde
nous avons apporté un peu de chaleur
tous les gens qui font l'expérience de
d'aller parler aux sans-abriquer en bas
de chez eux ils disent tous qui sont
agressifs et qui veulent pas qu'on leur
parle mais c'est marrant comme comme la
position d'avoir une association aide ça
aide et j'ai remarqué ce soir il vous
envoie pas bouler globalement non pas du
tout il y a eu personne qui nous a
envoyé non effectivement on a mais c'est
pour ça que alors peut-être oui il faut
peut-être le peut-être que le blouson il
aide ah ouais
alors il y a le thermos aussi qui aide
je pense que si ceux qui y vont avec un
thermos déjà il y a des gens un élément
de la panoplie c'est peut-être pas
forcément
un blouson ou un t-shirt ou quelque
chose mais effectivement de montrer
qu'on est dans ce cadre là ce qui est
dommage mais effectivement si ça marche
comme ça le blouson et le thermos la
panoplie du Maraudeur bye bye merci
beaucoup je vais vous rendre le blouson
à cet instant précis je pensais que
c'était quelque chose d'utile pour aller
au contact j'avais tort
certains maraudeurs travaillent les
mains dans les poches et ça marche aussi
[Musique]
il est 8h du matin à peine remis demain
soir avec l'Ordre de Malte je rechauffe
les baskets ce matin j'ai rendez-vous
dans le 10ème arrondissement de Paris
avec les équipes d'Emmaüs
bonjour
des familles en grande exclusion
son binôme est
depuis près de 20 ans dans le social
avant les SDF il s'occupait des
toxicomanes
à la différence de l'Ordre de Malte tous
ici sont salariés et travaillent sous
les ordres d'Hélène c'est quoi votre
secteur
et 18 ah oui c'est en gros secteur quand
même un très gros secteur le plus
souvent possible on fait des points
comme ça sur le territoire avec un
centre de l'équipe pour voir où il y a
du monde puisqu'il y a des fois où on va
aller plus vers un endroit pour marquer
les il y a carrément les prénoms des
prénoms
les travailleurs sociaux d'Emmaüs
pratiquent eux aussi la maraude
bon je suppose que ça commence par un
café non pas trop bonne journée
mais ici pas de blouson ciglé pas de
distribution de soupe
l'objectif c'est la sortie de rue un
travail sur le long terme
la plupart du temps notre travail c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte
d'accompagner les personnes sur la
première marche de l'insertion voilà et
ensuite on laisse la main au travers
sociaux des centres d'hébergement
pour passer la marche suivante
c'est les personnes qui sont plus très
très longtemps à la rue notre adresse
directement de l'hébergement d'urgence à
un logement parce que ça fait peut-être
10 ans qu'elles ont pas fait la cuisine
ça a été de 15 ans qu'elles n'ont pas
été toute seule dans un logement puis ça
aussi c'est angoissant et tout seul
[Musique]
remettre les exclus sur la première
marche de l'insertion
vaste programme d'autant que les
maraudeurs de Paris Nord suivent 150
personnes en moyenne
[Musique]
avec Emmaüs c'est assez sportif
aujourd'hui pas de camionnette une bonne
paire de chaussures suffira
[Musique]
ça marche bien
pour ce qui est des documents moi j'ai
tout ce que ce que tu m'as filé à avoir
des trucs de la Sécu il arrive qui m'a
eu suivent des gens pendant des années
c'est le cas de Pascal le premier
rendez-vous de l'équipe et là tu fais
ajouter un contact tu peux le faire
Pascal vient de récupérer un téléphone
portable mais après des années de rue il
a un peu de mal avec la technologie tu
appuies et après tu appuies sur l'étoile
et après tu fais ça
mon premier mon premier il est là dans
le canal le premier téléphone est dans
le canal
[Musique]
c'est le premier SDF français que je
croise
j'essaye d'en savoir plus sur son
parcours je ne suis pas au bout de mes
surprises
vous êtes un ancien banquier
comment un ancien banquier se
retrouve-t-il SDF je n'ose pas lui poser
la question
mais le sortir de la rue ne sera pas une
cinécure Pascal est bien enracinée dans
sa galère oh bah la journée je suis
l'homme et bon ici il a toujours
toujours tous les jours ici au pied de
cet arbre
et vous faites quoi de la journée
c'est vrai il me connaissent depuis
tellement d'années que
j'ai combien vous êtes dans la rue
[Musique]
vous avez quel âge 52 oh on a presque le
même âge
[Musique]
que moi
trois fois rien
trois fois rien 27 ans d'activité 15 ans
de rue
en fait Pascal ne peut pas avoir 52 ans
mais à sa décharge la rue détruit les
repères d'ailleurs mon nouvel ami n'a
même plus ses papiers elle est perdue
depuis quand cette carte oh ça fait deux
ans
j'en ai fait refaire trois en deux ans
donc la préfecture il commence à tousser
un peu ah ouais
la nuit
quand je dormais
seulement le foyer est provisoire et
sans carte d'identité impossible
d'entreprendre une vraie démarche de
relogement alors les nouveaux papiers de
Pascal c'est la mission du jour pour
Emmaüs
il est temps d'arracher Pascal à son
banc la chose n'est pas évidente Pascal
se déplace avec difficulté notre petite
équipe doit l'escorter jusqu'au
commissariat à 500 mètres à peine
[Musique]
des fois compliqué pour les gens
d'expliquer
quand on a été pendant un temps à la rue
d'aller dans les institutions on peut se
sentir mal à l'aise parce que on va
les autres vont nous regarder parce que
ça se voit qu'on vient de la rue et puis
pour n'importe qui déjà rien que ça pour
n'importe qui des fois c'est compliqué
de faire de faire les papiers quoi de
faire son passeport pour n'importe qui
c'est compliqué parce que là il y a
beaucoup de monde donc ça se trouve ils
vont lui dire revenez demain ou revenait
après-demain et lui déjà qu'il aura mis
toute son énergie à venir aujourd'hui il
va dire bon je voilà je laisse tomber et
pourtant cette formalité n'aura pris que
quelques secondes
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Pascal vous
tout seul vous l'auriez pas fait
si on me dit d'aller quelque part on
vient pas ma compagnie
j'y vais pas forcément
faut qu'ils aient la volonté pour pour
vous quoi
par les pieds accompagnés en SDF refaire
ses papiers cela pourrait sembler des
risoirs
pas de RSA pas de retraite et pas de
logement
aujourd'hui c'est un petit pas pour
Emmaüs mais c'est un grand pas pour
Pascal
la place n'a pas été prise
c'est une bonne place ici c'est une
bonne place ici
il y a du passage
Pascal finira peut-être par quitter la
place Stalingrad
[Musique]
au pied de son arbre
on n'est pas toujours heureux
[Musique]
ils vivent là vous avez envie de rentrer
là
[Musique]
ici 10h30
on va aller en chercher de nous on va
rechercher un nouveau plat
comment vous êtes retrouvés dans la rue
sans indiscrétion merci Madame
moi j'ai espoir pour toute personne que
je rencontre dans la rue
ma journée avec Emmaüs comment s'appelle
on t'a déjà dit que tu avais un côté un
petit côté Catherine Frot Catherine Frot
peut-être mais un peu moins rigolote
bon Catherine alors
[Musique]
je plaisante mais pour Hélène l'heure
n'est pas à la rigolade
si le 4 Pascal n'est pas simple à
résoudre il y a encore plus complexe la
communauté tamoul de la rue
[Musique]
rarement des Tamouls qui vivent en
France
vous parlez tous français
plus ou moins dans les années 2000 il
est à moules en massivement fuit la
guerre civile qui ravagait leur pays le
Sri Lanka
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 150 000 à
résider sur notre territoire
certains son clandestin mais beaucoup
ont le statut de réfugiés
35 ans
ce sont eux qui souvent font la plonge
ou la cuisine dans les restaurants
parisiens
la vaisselle
et maintenant fini
et vous dormez où
dans un dans un foyer d'hébergement
Emmaüs
vous avez envie de rentrer là
vous voulez rentrer traumatisé par la
guerre sans repère ces hommes sont les
victimes d'une migration ratée qui se
soldent par une descente aux enfers
je comprends pourquoi les maraudeurs
d'Emmaüs ont recensé 6 morts en deux ans
sur le seul secteur de Paris Nord
salut
Hélène Ali et Johanna font tout
particulièrement attention à cette
communauté
mais leur travail n'est pas simple cette
situation
[Musique]
tout expliquer ce jeune homme par
exemple bien que né sur le territoire il
parle à peine français moi je tombais la
tresse
Johanna se bat pour lui ouvrir des
droits
[Musique]
je t'explique le problème c'est qu'il
est incapable de se prendre en charge
tout seul
rendez-vous vendredi 28 février
incapable d'honorer les rendez-vous que
lui organise la jeune femme il
faut que tu
il a déjà imprimé
je comprends que les 100 abris de Paris
n'ont que la galère en commun
à part ça leur problème sont tous
différents et la manière de les résoudre
aussi
[Musique]
je te laisse mettre ton nom ici
voilà pourquoi l'outil indispensable du
travailleur de rue c'est la patience et
la foi dans son action
ce qui me concerne c'est des gens qui me
touchent sur la majorité des gens qui
sont dans la rue c'est des gens
ils viennent m'interpeller au plus
profond de moi-même de la même manière
qu'ils interpellent l'équipe mais là sur
ces questions c'est intime quoi donc je
parle en mon nom mais moi j'ai espoir
pour toute personne que je rencontre
dans la rue sinon je ferais pas ça sans
vocation impossible de faire ce métier
mais il faut aussi savoir se préserver
Hélène aime son travail mais avec le
temps elle a appris à se protéger de la
rue on est payé on est
revenu
effectivement je fais ce métier par
choix c'est un métier que j'ai vraiment
choisi mais ça reste un métier je rentre
chez moi le soir je vais mettre du poids
je reviens pas voir comment tout le
monde va
alors juste pour
vous
[Musique]
la journée s'achève avec des kilomètres
dans les pattes l'équipe d'Emmaüs
voudrait me montrer encore quelque chose
l'un des 10 jardins potagers d'Emmaüs
dans la capitale
un atelier certes mais surtout un lieu
de rencontre privilégié entre les
éducateurs de rue et les sans-abris
rendez-vous vendredi
vendredi après demain avec Ahmed ici
10h30
donc elles vont très hautes
et l'animateur de ce jardin
cultiver et du coup là-bas ça part un
peu aussi en création parce que Dimitar
voilà nous a proposé un peu spécialiste
du macramé imitant vient presque tous
les jours c'est grâce à ça qu'ils ne
sombre pas
la travailler
la Bulgarie il y a quelques années il
cherchait une vie meilleure il a échoué
sur le macadam parisien sa planche de
salut c'est son petit artisanat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
français
[Musique]
et du coup il a fait plusieurs créations
macramé
on a l'impression d'un gars qui qui
vient d'attraper un tout petit fil qui
est en train de tirer dessus alors en
plus c'est très adapté à ce qui fait
c'est via le savoir qu'il avait il
peut remercier les gens qui l'aide et
d'être retrouvé de la dignité
ce petit jardin symbolise bien le
travail des Maraudeurs d'Emmaüs il faut
beaucoup de temps de patience et
d'attention quotidienne pour au final
récolter de toutes petites victoires
contre l'exclusion
[Musique]
il est 18h30 nous sommes de retour en
bord de Seine sur le Florent Saint-Jean
la péniche refuge de l'Ordre de Malte
parce que je trouve ça en fait c'est
très joli le soir bord de la Seine et je
trouve que c'est sympa pour eux de voir
la scène
pour nous aussi d'ailleurs
quelquefois on a des canards qui
viennent on a même des signes qui
viennent de temps en temps alors ils
adorent donner du pain et tout ça
[Musique]
chaque jeudi Annick pose son blouson de
maraudeuse pour enfiler le tablier de
cantinière
on est bien organisé on se partage tout
dans 30 minutes les pensionnaires de ce
drôle de refuge vont rentrer ils seront
fatigués et ils auront le ventre creux
merci
couper le pain comment ça couper le pain
il faut donc s'activer pour que tout
soit prêt à temps
en réalité cette péniche n'est pas qu'un
restaurant pour sans abri depuis sa
création à la fin des années 90 c'est
aussi le foyer provisoire d'une
cinquantaine de SDF
je vais partager leur dîner
je sais pas est-ce que vous avez le menu
Roselyne
et pas de vent
non
voilà pendant que je papote avec
l'équipe ce qu'on appelle pudiquement
les passagers arrivent en un
[Musique]
pardon monsieur je vous gêne bonsoir
vous allez bien
il doit pointer avant de récupérer la
clé de leur cabine
Jean-Claude fait partie des 50 passagers
c'est pas facile il est ici depuis
quelques mois déjà et tout son univers
tient dans cette cabine de 2 mètres
carrés
en galère
voilà
ce minuscule refuge et provisoire
alors je vais me laver les mains
dans 3 mois
Jean-Claude devra trouver une autre
solution
et si cette précarité ne les ferait pas
c'est parce que depuis son divorce il y
a 30 ans il bourlingue de foyer en
squats
quand on fait le calcul à 63 ans
Jean-Claude a passé près de la moitié de
sa vie dans la rue du coup un lit une
douche suffit à son bonheur pourvu que
ce soit propre et qu'il soit tranquille
voilà
alors quand on est aussi peu difficile
que cette éternel passager le Florent
Saint-Jean c'est l'idéal lui rappelle la
politique
comme beaucoup de centres d'hébergement
la péniche est fermée le jour les
passagers doivent lever le camp tous les
matins à 8h qu'il pleuve ou qu'ils vante
alors quand on ne travaille pas les
journées à l'extérieur sont parfois très
longues
en ce moment demain oui demain faut que
j'aille aux impôts récupérer une feuille
d'impôt pour aller voir mon référence
sociale la semaine prochaine voilà
en 2012 la non imposition si on veut la
feuille de nom imposition ah non tu veux
quoi
bah oui faut pas travailler sinon vous
payez des impôts
et vous lâche pas
je suis surpris par cette atmosphère
paisible
[Musique]
pour un peu j'oublierai que je suis dans
un hébergement d'urgence
[Musique]
c'est-à-dire que je me demande si parmi
eux il y a pas plein de gens qui
travaillent en fait
on a l'impression qu'il rentre du boulot
[Musique]
pourtant je suis bien dans un refuge
et où commande il y a Monique la
directrice c'est elle qui veille
discrètement sur ce petit coin de
sérénité
et comment est-ce que vous retrouvez là
vous j'ai travaillé dans le handicap
dans le logement bon maintenant je suis
toujours dans des structures sociales
toujours
c'est un travail là où on est pris quand
même 7 sur 7 puis la soirée donc je
pense que c'est un travail aussi où
qu'on peut faire quand on n'est pas
jeune mère de famille enfin quand les
enfants sont un peu il faut que ça soit
grand
ah oui c'est ça bouffe la vie un peu
comme ça
mais il y a des bénévoles ici qui sont
très fidèles puisque ça fait 15 ans qui
sont à 14 ans
une fois par semaine
il reste une vingtaine de minutes avant
le repas
pendant que des Parisiens festivois sur
la péniche d'à côté
passager bénévoles patiente à leur façon
je décide de patienter avec eux
en fait je cherche en moyenne d'entamer
la conversation avec Eric l'homme au 900
euros d'impôts
seulement eric est concentré sur son jeu
il est en train de coller une raclée au
bénévole de service
on est obligé de manger
je me souvenais pas de cette règle je
dois donc attendre la fin de la partie
pour briser la glace avec ce passager
doux et réservé
vous venez vous faire battre souvent aux
dames
j'ai profité des erreurs
toute la journée non non juste le matin
parce qu'après tu étais un peu Pôle
Emploi
chercher du boulot et ben dans ma
situation on prend un peu n'importe quoi
même manœuvre
même de la plonge dans les restaurants
on va le prendre
mais bon moi je suis une tranche d'âge
j'ai 49 ans
j'ai pas encore 50 ans donc je passe pas
dans les seniors et j'ai moins de 50 ans
donc je suis plus jeune donc
je suis dans vraiment dans une tranche
d'âge vraiment la pire comment vous êtes
retrouvé dans la rue sans indiscrétion
j'ai démissionné de l'administration
un coup de tête
vous pensiez à votre bon étoile à
l'époque c'est ça j'ai pas trop réfléchi
en fait
et vos journées dans la rue c'est quoi
en général quand il fait beau bah
c'est promenade ou alors s'installer
dans un parc à bouclier
vous faites la Manche non
donc vous vivez de quoi de
RSA je l'ai fait un petit moment en 2008
comme la majorité des passagers ici
[Musique]
Eric se débrouille avec les 439 euros
mensuels de RSA
une somme suffisante pour survivre
survivre uniquement
on va aller en chercher de nous on va
rechercher un nouveau plat
manger plus que j'ai mangé
[Musique]
un défaut d'un menu gastronomique on ne
lésine pas sur la quantité
il est 20h30 en cuisine il y a le feu
ce soir c'est Olivier qui tire les
reines du fourneau
Olivier a vécu très longtemps à Rome
c'est là-bas qu'il a découvert l'Ordre
de Malte
de retour en France il a souhaité
poursuivre son engagement mais bien
évidemment comme les autres bénévoles
Olivier a une autre vie
je suis pas cristaux je suis plutôt
banquier
et le banquier de l'humour il emploie
déborquer comme ils sont en train
d'écrire ces jours-ci donc il faut
qu'elle les défendre un peu
il y a de bonbons
vous avez envie de faire quelque chose
enfin
de nécessité autant aller là où il y a
vraiment quelque chose à faire pendant
que Olivier transpire dans sa cuisine de
poche
je dîne avec les passagers
ce soir Jean-Paul est mon voisin de
table au menu il y a de la dinde et des
farfalles
[Musique]
le tout est servi dans une ambiance
bonne enfant
[Musique]
300 là
entre la poire et le yaourt j'essaye
tout de même de savoir si Jean-Claude le
recordman de la rue n'en a pas marre
d'être SDF à 63 ans
possède l'insouciance de ce qui n'ont
rien à perdre
et à bien y réfléchir sa philosophie est
un peu à l'image du refuge
[Musique]
sur cette péniche on vit au présent sans
penser Roland histoire d'oublier la
galère
au moins le temps d'une soirée
journaliste pour ta première page tu
peux écrire comme ce que tu veux
je t'en pratique trop formidable la
ballade des gens heureux
il est plus de 22h je laisse mes
nouveaux amis à leur chanson
en fait ils vont aller se coucher puis
moi je vais rentrer à la maison mais je
suis mais totalement séduit par ce lieu
je peux dire les choses avec franchise
quand on arrive on voit les dames
patronesses et on se dit ça va pas le
faire et ça va être froid comme endroit
et en fait c'est vachement chaleureux le
repas a été juste extraordinaire ces
bonhommes
ont une épaisseur incroyable il y a des
histoires hallucinantes
ils sont même pas totalement bousillés
et puis les dames patronales celles-ci
elles sont utiles
et de le courant passe entre elles quoi
il y a une sorte de petite famille là
qui s'est constituée derrière qui est
super émouvant
j'ai habité ce quartier pendant 10 ans
j'avais jamais fait attention à ce qui
se passait là et je trouve ce lieu
magnifique et ces gens-là
extraordinaires tous
des dames patronesses
au dernier des sans-abris qui sont là
quoi je suis content que celui existe et
et j'ai passé une plus belle soirée de
depuis un paquet de temps avec ces
gens-là
il est temps pour moi de partir vers de
nouveaux horizons demain ailleurs j'ai
rendez-vous avec d'autres hommes et
d'autres femmes au VIPER
[Musique]